[Music]
stu sheller spent 17 years as united
states marine corps officer five combat
deployments in iraq and afghanistan to
this day shell remains the only person
in the united states punished in any way
for the debacle of the withdrawal from
afghanistan he criticized it they sent
him to jail for it
we sat down for his first interview
since leaving jail and it was
fascinating here's part of it
[Music]
so this had been building up for a while
so anyone that has been there and
experienced it that's very personal
and so in the age that we lived i was
watching the afghanistan plan fall apart
before our eyes social media real time
it was very frustrating and i was
talking to my family i was talking to my
friends i was having a real hard time
with it
and then about a week previous to it the
commandant of the marine corps released
a white letter
that stated you know was your sacrifices
worth it addressing all of us struggling
with what we were struggling with
and he stated if you are having trouble
you need to go seek therapy
but he never pointed out that anyone any
senior leader might be culpable for
wrongdoings and i saw that as him
placing his loyalty to the other general
officers and not to the junior enlisted
we could have all avoided the trip to
the therapist had he admitted that
senior leaders had fault so i was angry
about that i was angry about how it was
handled
and then a week later the unit that got
attacked was my first unit when i was in
ramadi my best friend got hit with an s
vest in one eight
it came full circle to me i was the
regimental operations officer officer
that put one eight out on deployment i
knew all the company commanders i knew
the battalion so i knew the opposite i
intimately knew this unit and since then
i had moved on to become a battalion
commander
and all of this just got to a point
where i knew for a fact that no senior
leaders were going to be held
accountable
i knew that i was going to be held
accountable but at a certain point we
need to publicly address our shortfalls
we're going to keep repeating the same
mistakes and so
you know even after i made that video i
made the video in my office i didn't
post it right away i drove to my house
and you know you're outside your house
you got your your wife and your three
kids inside the house come on and i'm
pacing around the front of the house
like on my phone like you know like the
butt the away knowing that that's going
to change your life forever
um
and i made the decision to put that out
there
but why
i mean everything you said i i think
everyone understands your frustrations
but you're clearly smart
so you sort of knew maybe you know you
go to jail for it but you knew
you know but you did it anyway so but
why did you do that
this has been my whole life you know my
whole adult life has been dedicated to
america foreign diplomacy i wrote a
master's thesis on how to make foreign
diplomacy more effective
um
there's no one more personally invested
than me you know i've
awards for valor
but all that's irrelevant
when you know i'm watching the junior
service member win every tactical
engagement
in the future that our general officers
right now are talking about the shift of
the force the national security strategy
it's all predicated on changes on the
tactical level how to mature the force
distributed operations that's all
tactical level stuff we've won every
tactical level engagement what we're
losing at is the operational level where
general mckenzie and the combatant
commanders reside and that link between
the strategic level and the national
security council the secretary of
defense and the president those are the
people that need to be addressed and be
held accountable because these junior
enlisted are going out there sacrificing
everything i would submit sacrificing
more than the general officers are and
they're not getting the credit they
deserve
and so you ask me like why i did it and
those are the men you command yes i i
was a company commander in multiple
different commands i've been a company
commander at school of infantry i was a
company commander in 3-2 a weapons
company commander and a headquarters
company commander was a company
commander at the basic school for a
bunch of officers so community i've been
a company commander for five years i had
been selected a battalion command i was
in
my battalion command seat for about
two months before i made that video so
it was pretty short-lived
and they fired me
before dinner the next night you know so
that was uh
but
i did it because not only was i
personally invested
following vietnam there was no general
officers that were held accountable and
the narrative that's told today is how
the general officers had to basically
clean up the draft generation and make
good service members but they never went
back and held themselves accountable and
the exact same thing is happening right
now
they're taking hey the g watt generation
doesn't know how to fight china we need
to change it it's the tactical problems
and they're not focusing on the
operational strategic problems which are
the same things that should have been
addressed after vietnam and we're not
and the reason they kind of got washed
away is because we had a marginal
success in desert storm in the 90s and
that just kind of threw us off
in terms of the systemic changes that
need to take place and so all of those
reasons are why i feel like
you know it's not my place to say it and
everyone pointed that out
but there's nobody else saying it
you know there's just nobody else saying
it
stu sheller
a really brave man and an honorable man
exactly the sort of person you want
defending your country that whole
conversation is available right now on
fox nation head over tuckercarlson.com
if you want to see it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else